welcome to my list of 21 more nooby
python habits, I'm also giving away
pycharm licenses so get your
#pycharm down in the comments to enter
nooby habits are things that noobs do
that doesn't mean they're wrong or bad
or that you can't or shouldn't use them
but nonetheless they tip off other
developers to your inexperience and
avoiding them tends to improve your code
so whether you're brand spanking new to
python or just trying to keep that
awesome tech job you somehow got let's
dive in.
nooby thing #1, manually
rounding inside a print statement, you
computed some value and it's time to
print it out, but it's a floating point
value, if you just print it out as is
it's too many digits, too much clutter
so you just round it, right?
instead just use a format specifier.
#2, repeatedly converting to and
from numpy arrays, often accidentally. in
most data analysis situations the best
thing is usually to just immediately
convert your data into numpy arrays or
pandas data frames then just make sure
you stick to all numpy or pandas
functions, it's a pretty common mistake
to actually use a non-numpy function
like the built-in max which results in
even worse performance than using max
on a list. #3 manipulating
paths as strings. for obvious reasons
it's very common to represent a path as
a string, so there's the obvious
temptation to do string operations to
manipulate the paths. but this approach
is highly error prone. instead consider
using the built-in pathlib. pathlib
already has built-in most of the common
file and directory manipulations that
you would want to do. #4 writing
IO functions that take the path instead
of an IO object. there's nothing really
wrong with having a convenience function
that does this but what you should
really do is have a separate function
that does all of the writing operations.
so this function does all of the logic
of writing to the file and this function
is just a convenient wrapper around it.
the reason for doing this especially if
you're writing a library is that people
might not want to open a file, or they
might want to be writing to a different
kind of IO object like to a zip file, to
a network connection, or to a string. by
providing this version of the function
you allow people to write to whatever
they want to instead of just to a file...
and speaking of writing to a string, that
brings us to our next nooby habit
concatenating strings with plus. the plus
operation on a string copies the string
so in this for loop I end up making 100
copies of a larger and larger string.
instead use a StringIO object. this
uses a growing in-memory buffer to
minimize the number of copies of the
string data and it has an interface just
like a file object that you'd get from
open, and once you're ready to convert
the buffer back into an actual string
object, call getvalue. #6, put a
finger down if you've never done this
one, using eval as a parser.
through dubious means you've got a
string with a data structure in it. just
pass it to eval, what could possibly go
wrong?
well of course the answer is eval is bad
and you should feel bad for trying.
okay okay eval does have some legitimate
uses, but parsing data from a string
isn't one I would probably use in
production. instead consider using an
actual parsing Library like the built-in
json. #7 and this one really
pains me to see, storing your function
inputs and or outputs as global
variables. if you're reading from a
global and using it to change something
about how your function works, then
consider it might be better if it's just
an input parameter, and if you're writing
to a global variable it should probably
be somewhere in your return value.
hey, while you're here, did you know that
I'm available for consulting? that's
right, self promo! my team does python
consulting, contracting, training, and
interview prep. if you're interested,
visit mcoding.io. #8 thinking
"and" and "or" return bools. you may not have
ever printed out the results of an "and"
or an "or" because you typically just use
them in "if" statements. but if you did you
might have been surprised at the results.
you don't get a True or False in general.
"or" returns the first truthy thing or
the last falsy thing, and "and" returns the
first falsy thing or the last truthy
thing. #9 single letter
variables. there are of course cases
where single letter variables are fine, a
single underscore to denote something unused,
calling a loop variable "i", common
conventions like x, y, and z coordinates,
or even well-known math formulas. no, what
I'm talking about is a whole function
where everything is just a single letter
or maybe two. with just a few carefully
thought out variable names it would be
so much easier to understand.
#10 using both div and mod instead
of divmod. if you're doing, like, math I
guess? there's a decent chance that
you'll want to divide by a number and
know both the quotient and remainder
that's what divmod does, it gives you
both a quotient and the remainder
without repeating the calculation.
#11 not knowing about properties. a
lot of noobs, especially people coming
from java, are in the habit of writing
getters and setters for every variable.
the more pythonic thing is to just leave
the variable as part of the public
interface but sometimes we use getters
and setters because we want to actually
do something in them. in that case having
a separate get and set function does
make sense, but doing that means that in
order to access the value I'm now
calling functions set_x and get_x
instead of the more intuitive dot notation.
well that's exactly what a property lets
us do. now because of descriptor magic we
can just say object.x equals 42 and that
will actually call the setter with the
value being 42. and on a related note
#12 having expensive properties.
cool cool you learned what a property is
and now it's time to save two characters
on every function call by converting
them into properties. slow down there.
it's not about saving characters.
anything that takes much longer than
just a normal attribute access shouldn't
be turned into a property. if you have a
function that might be very expensive
make it look expensive.
#13 inserting or deleting while
iterating.
here we're looping over the dictionary
and while that iteration is in progress
we try to delete a key. for a dictionary,
doing this is going to raise a runtime
error, but for other data types
especially C extension types this
might just do something very weird and
not throw any error. replacing or
modifying a value on the other hand is
typically fine. another approach is to
keep a set of keys that you're going to
delete, loop over the dictionary and add
anything that you want to delete into
the to_delete set. then once you're done
delete all of the keys afterwards.
#14 and I know this will be controversial,
any use of filter or map. the reason is
that they encourage you to write code
that looks like this.
in general you can replace any filter
like thism and you can replace any map
like this,
these generator comprehensions are lazy
just like filter and map and they
produce the same elements, and bonus
points if you were just immediately
going to convert that to a list. instead
you could use a list comprehension which
is even more readable.
...and it's tomorrow. who could have guessed
that yelling python into a microphone
for two hours was bad for your voice? but
you're worth it, 14 down let's keep going.
#15 defining too many or
inappropriate dunder methods. some of
them like init or hash make
perfect sense to define for most classes.
but the Person class does not represent
any kind of number or thing that
naturally has a plus operation
associated with it. but this code goes
ahead and defines iadd to make
plus-equals mean make these two people
friends. don't use a dunder method to
accomplish this task, just use a normal
function with a good name. #16
trying to parse HTML or XML using
regular expressions. it's not that you
made a mistake, that your regular
expression is bad or that you're not
smart enough to come up with the
complete one that handles all the edge
cases. it's literally impossible to
create a regular expression that can
parse HTML because HTML is not a regular
language. instead you're going to need an
actual parser. you could use something
like Python's built-in HTML parser or
you could reach for a more full featured
third-party library like BeautifulSoup,
which of course has a parser inside of
it. #17 not knowing about raw string
literals. in most srings it doesn't matter,
but specifically for Windows paths and
in regular expressions, using literal
backlashes is very common. plop down an "r"
in front of your string to make it a raw
string literal. raw strings ignore escape
sequences, making regular expressions
much easier to read.
#18 thinking that super means parent. you
might think that the super call is going
to call the Root's version of "f", and in
most cases you'd be right, but not in all
cases.
and the reason is that someone could
inherit from your class. this instance of
C is also an instance of A but when we
call "f" we see that the chain of super
calls goes from C to A to B to Root. in
particular this super call inside of A
right after printing "A.f" sent us to
the sibling class B, not to A's parent
Root. I've got a whole video on super if
you'd like to hear more.
#19 passing structured data around as a
raw dictionary or tuple. you do some
calculation, take a measurement, or
summarize some data. if these values are
meaningful and always need to stick
together, then most likely this should be
a class and you should give it a name. if
you were returning a dictionary before, a
data class is probably what you want, and
if you were returning a tuple, then a
NamedTuple is probably what you want.
#20 using collections namedtuple instead
of typing NamedTuple. back in the day
this was a best-practice because it
allowed you to give tuple elements good
names. but nowadays the typing NamedTuple
is a much more readable way to do
the same thing. it actually looks like a
class definition, it's easy to read, and
doesn't rely on strings. and as always
saving the best for last, #21
import-time side effects.
please please please don't print
something when I import your module. even
if your library can also be used as a
script and that's the behavior that you
want when you run the script, use the
"def main if name main" idiom to hide it
behind a "main" function. that's another
one where I've got a whole video
explaining the benefits of doing this.
and that's 21. you must really love the
sound of my voice, or maybe you just like
my content in which case don't forget to
subscribe and become one of my patrons
on patreon. itching for more nooby
habits? check out my first nooby habits
video.
as always thank you to my patrons and
donors for their support, slap that like
button an odd number of times, and I'll
see you next time